um
well i mean like you say every every
every year it's different like you have
like
one year it was neta and with her song
thai from israel
and then the next year it's duncan
lawrence uh with like this big emotional
ballad sir
i think i feel like you know we got
these we also got a brief
um from like loads of eurovision kind of
um
boffins and it was like it can't be in
um the tempo between 110 and 124
bpm because that's bloody pop and that
never wins apart from one song
and the key of c is too happy
for eurovision so there's like all these
kind of rules but i think
mainly it's just writing something that
connects with people that feels
that captures a moment or captures a
feeling
um of what's happening at the time and
something that people can connect to in
some sort of way you know if it's an
emotional song then
you know it gets them there and if it's
done you know
it's if it's fun and it's exciting then
that could get people in and
um for me like i wanted to do something
that
had a memorable hook that you didn't
have to know the lyrics to as well
because you know there's 41 countries
and
not everyone can speak my language so if
if it's a moment where you can just sing
along without having to know the words i
think that's
really important maybe um but i don't
know
it's it's there's no i don't think there
is a formula i think it's just a feeling
that you have to try and
uh catch onto